you
Bernard Tyson good to have you thank you
very much this is the industrialist
dilemma where we're talking about both
new startups and disruptive companies
that are changing industries as well as
how some of the largest incumbents in
those industries are responding to
digital transformation and and what we
wanted you here today to talk about what
kaisers doing to really kind of
transform healthcare in this digital era
so maybe just as a kind of kicking it
off and and then starting off I don't
know if you want to describe this state
from your perspective of kind of
healthcare today and in 2016 like what
what is the environment like what are
the the big problems and how do you see
Kaiser fitting into that you know with
or without the digital angle I guess I
would start with is in the midst of the
most massive amount of change that I've
seen in my career in healthcare and for
sure in Kaiser Permanente and it has
really taken off over the last I would
say seven years eight years and it's the
thing called the Affordable Care Act the
Affordable Care Act did two things one
it provided access to millions of
Americans to get into the front door the
American health care system and number
two it put a couple hundred billion
dollars of new money into the healthcare
arena and everyone has been going after
that and it's all based on a theory that
the American healthcare system is broken
and what we need to bring into the
industry is new ideas new talent new
innovation new technology and disrupt an
old system that was fundamentally
designed to do a couple of things one to
intervene when a person got sick so it
was a fixme system it was designed to
pay for volume so it encouraged doing
more of something and it was designed in
a very fragmented way so if you look at
the history of healthcare in America
people used to
young so there was no real need for
health care you just died and then we we
ostensibly solved that part and then and
then a couple of things happened a
couple of things happened one we learned
how to deal with waste and sanitation
and number two we learned how to process
foods so people started to live longer
and as people started to live longer
stuff started to happen to the body and
the healthcare system was fixed B system
it will something happen let's fix it
and that's how the industry grew up so
what we have today is a healthcare
system in which someone is birth and
born and then someone dies right this
the healthcare system is financed
towards the last year and a half of a
person's life so about 75% of the
healthcare dollars are actually spent on
about 20% of the population and of that
75% that is spent on the 20% of the
population about 90% of that 75% is
actually spent in the last 12 to 18
months of a person's life so you have an
entire health care system that is
financed towards the end state of a
person's life so the question that I get
to work on and what I'm trying to do in
transform in the industry is based on
the fundamentals of what Kaiser
Permanente is about which is prevention
which is to say the best cure is to
prevent or catch something early and
therefore you can treat it in a more
efficient way effective way and prolong
the what we call the healthy life years
of an individual so the question is what
kind of model do we want to build in the
21st century do we want to continue with
a sick care model and do we want that
model to be an intervention model which
will lead to what we have today that
when you need to be in the hospital
that's an intervention
the hospital do you want a wellness
model that begins to incent and engage
the in this case the American people in
a different narrative which is a big
part of what's going on is your
responsibility it's called what you eat
what you drink how you treat your body
how you exercise or the lack thereof and
then there are other things that are
just happening to the body that comes
with aging and or genetics and
hereditary illnesses right so I would
offer to you inside of that context to
figure out how to redesign the
healthcare industry in which the dollars
that are expended here are being
repurposed through the lifetime of the
person's life with the objective of
living longer and living more healthy
life years and and what is it about
kaisers either business model or
structure that that lets you guys sort
of take advantage of this strategy that
is different from other kind of
hospitals and healthcare providers well
actually many of your students touched
on it and spoke to it by the way you
have a smart class all right god I mean
that my wife went to Stanford I couldn't
go to Stanford Stanford smart they got
that one wrong then yeah and it came up
in in this discussion one is our
incentives are aligned and I'll touch on
that in a second the second one is we
have the end-to-end process so when the
Kaiser Permanente system is to use this
analogy when you give me the dollar I'm
responsible for everything and so I get
to take the dollar and with my doctor's
look at the best distribution of that
dollar along the whole healthcare
continuum and so our physicians are not
incentive or disincentive in a different
way if a patient needs to be in a
hospital
or in a nursing home or in the medical
office building or you pick the spot
because we own the entire healthcare
dollar in the hospital industry you only
own a piece of that dollar and your
revenue is is given when you have what
we call a head in the bed so in my
system a hospital is an expense center
for me it's not a revenue Center I
already have the dollar and so I can
build a system of care and the reason
why our hospital days are more effective
than almost anyone in the industry is
because when you're done in the hospital
I have a warm handoff to the outpatient
in the rest of the industry when you are
done with the hospital you're done with
the hospital the the third piece is that
the alignment of the physician and the
other medical professions to the health
plan is tight and what I mean by that is
in the industry most of the provider
side feels like they are in war with the
quote insurance I in my business model I
do the coverage and the care and so my
doctors sit at the table with me and we
talked about the 10.5 million members
that we now are honored to take care of
and what's the infrastructure that we
need to continue to build to do that so
you get to the question that I think
well all the time if I was redesigning
if I was rebuilding Kaiser Permanente
today versus how my forefathers did it
god bless him I wouldn't start with a
hospital the beginning of Kaiser
Permanente was a hospital that then
eventually grew into an integrated
system if I was building Kaiser
Permanente today I would start with
technology I would start with my
technology platform and then everything
else will follow that why would I do
that because the entire healthcare
system is also built around everybody
coming to it
that's the way it was designed and what
we are proving that Kaiser Permanente is
that you can distribute care out so
someone mentioned for example the use of
the mobile phone last year we did almost
30 million secure a visit that's between
the member and the physician I'm now
putting 300 and something million
dollars into building an entire digital
platform
why because telehealth is also going to
be our future where with high definition
you pick it I pad iPhone TV you pick it
we will be able to create visits between
our members and a physician that is not
only more efficient all the way around
because the member does not have to
drive across town park talk to her
reception is take off their clothes wait
in a room read an old magazine although
we have new magazine write and do all of
that it's a direct relationship between
the physician and between the members in
our almost 30 million visits on last
year on a scale of one to ten the
ratings of that is something like 9.3
9.4 so the level of satisfaction is
extremely high it's possible though
because the physician has the
relationship with the member and so one
the relationship is there and to every
one of my 10.5 million members as a
longitudinal electronic health record
and my requirements of the organization
of IT is that the systems must be a
99.9999
9% of the time and so the information
must always be readily available in the
hands of the physicians and authorized
users when that interactions happens
between the member and the system okay
so I don't need to pitch you on digital
it seems what are you seeing other if
you're not a fully integrated provider
is are you just directly disincentivized
from doing these things or you can you
literally not do them because your
relationship but the patient is entirely
different or like why can Kaiser do this
and your average hospital you know can't
do it I'm the digital piece ya know a
lot of a lot of a lot of healthcare
organization is trying to figure out how
to get into the digital piece and what
are the smart investments to to make
they're one of the challenges though is
if you are running a hospital system you
are subject to whether or not the
physician and the insurance company
wants to use you from one year to the
next and so if you're running a hospital
system and you have to continuously
think about what's the level of
assurance that I'll have this physician
population admitting patients into my
hospital over the next year there's a
level of uncertainty because many of the
physicians in the community setting
could have access to Aetna and United
and the Blues at the same time and so
changing from one insurance company to
the next is something that can happen
very fast in my system the physicians
are fully engaged exclusive to me and
the relationship is such that it is
long-term the second thing is our
patients our members stay with us much
longer than they do in the other
healthcare system and so you do ask
yourself the value proposition of the
investments that you would make and then
whether or not you
would have enough of a continuous
population to provide that guy gotten
over to it for payback how do you
determine where you need to invest in
technology development versus where you
want to partner with people on the
outside that's a great question it's a
great question
it's a it's a sea change inside of
Kaiser Permanente because we have we
have and we've had a lot of smart people
in the technology part of our
organization I think I have something
like almost 6,000 employees that work in
IT I'm a big time technology believer
and what we were doing though is because
we have such a complicated model we had
two major problems we've always used
technology and Kaiser Permanente we have
this thing called legacy systems and
they are very very very expensive when
the government had the problem when they
first introduced the Affordable Care Act
and you remember the big issue was that
the system wouldn't work I got
healthcare.gov the some of you have not
all of you know the real issue behind it
was it was a system put on top of legacy
systems and somebody forgot to look at
it from in the end is my version of this
and so they turned on the switch and and
you know part of the light came on over
here over here a didn't it so what you
ended up with was the lack of a seamless
system now to do what needs to get done
we have the same identical issues in
Kaiser Permanente that we built
Taizo Permanente from is history with
technology that grew with the
organization and so we've had legacy
systems in place and so when you bring
the 21st century technology into my
environment and our systems have been
built to match our model as much as
possible so everything is integrated
mm-hmm so when I put in a new pharmacy
system that we completed last year what
will suppose it cost me like five
hundred million dollars cost over a
billion dollars and the billion dollars
is because
we had to plug it in to all of our other
systems so we create the whole
integrated approach for our members now
why can I invest that kind of money in
there
it's because drugs are very expensive
and drugs is a part of our therapeutic
medicine and so for us is very important
if we give you 30 days worth of diabetes
medicine and is now 35 days and you
haven't reordered your medicine it's
very important to us that we figure out
what's not working in our relationship
that you are potentially not taking your
medication you go to the rest of the
world it's all about the distribution of
the drug and that's it and so what we
now are looking at is what are the right
strategic partners across the board and
so we have relationship with Google and
Apple Microsoft and and IBM we are heavy
now into cloud technology how to decide
what should be in the cloud and what
must be in our data center I mean that's
a sea change because I usually have to
look at buying data centers as much as I
had to look at buying medical office
buildings because of the amount of data
that we accumulate and that we store so
that's really been a sea change for us
to partner with expert technology
companies that can do it faster more
efficiently and then the challenge
become how to plug it in to an
organization like Kaiser Permanente that
has still has a lot of legacy systems
one thing that that has been a theme of
a lot of the kind of incumbents or sort
of traditionally industrial companies is
that they're held back by that baggage
they're held back by those legacy
systems and then they have disruptors
come in and they're building in the
cloud you know on by scratch modern
systems how do you ensure that that
Kaiser isn't sort of either moving too
slowly or held back by or anchored by
maybe there's legacy technologies have
you given your technology group as some
sort of mandate of of X amount has to be
new in this in this in a refactored way
or like how do you ensure that the
organization doesn't sort of grind to a
halt because of those legacy systems
yeah it's not just ID though I would say
that the secret in our situation because
the the the the technology is so
critical to everything that we do at
kaiser permanente everything that we do
at kaiser permanente so if you came into
my environment you will not see me with
just the technology people at the table
telling me how great it is you would you
would come into my office and you will
see doctors and you will see hospital
administrators and you would see the
people who are actually doing the work
because the some companies decide that
they want to use technology to
absolutely disrupt the operations and to
force change
that's not my strategy I'm very clear my
organization technology is an enablement
of the strategies of how we run and
provide healthcare and so my physicians
sit down and look at and imagine how
technology is going to help them to
become more efficient and effective we
do have technology that will naturally
disrupt but the technology has evolved
in Kaiser Permanente in part because we
already have the integrated system right
now we're looking at how to leverage
that to the next level it seems like
your physician base and the the medical
base in general you'd imagine that
there's probably resistance in other
Hospital environments because they it is
a sort of direct their disincentivize
from not having the patient come in and
see them because of the building
structure in the financial model but for
you the the physician is essentially
inherently you know interested or and
intended to make sure that the patient
is as healthy as possible is that have
you structured that yeah but but but I
don't want to I mean the challenges that
we have for example when we went to
electronic health record we have many
physicians who
were fearful of the invasion of
technology on their practice and so if
you have traditionally been a high-touch
hands-on physician and now all of a
sudden you're in a room with a patient
and you got to think as much about what
I'm putting on on the line as I am
taking care of the patient that's a it's
a generational gap of how to deal with
that right versus the newer younger who
just grew up with the technology and
it's a natural life so we had those kind
of cultural issues to deal with when we
began to introduce in particularly the
technology into the exam room
fast forward I'm now building a set of
new medical office buildings where the
technology is right in front of the
patient and the physician and we're
bringing in 21st century chairs that no
longer you're gonna have the little
Gurney's in the in the room you get you
sit down we take your weight from the
chair you're gonna be looking at a
high-definition screen in the room and
then if the when the physician gets
ready to examine you you're gonna push
my little iPad button and the seat is
gonna roll back if my way they're gonna
be some nice mellow music going off so
it so it's gonna all be about the whole
experience foot massage yeah we might
okay cool thank you so if you've got
just under two hundred thousand
employees where do you look to spend
your time in a very complex organization
physicians taking care of patients
you've got to run and off the operations
of a hospital you're looking at new
technology which is shiny and fun where
do you as the CEO look to spend your
time and how do you pass that on through
the culture of such a large organization
yeah that's a great question I probably
spend well his question is the great
questions
so some of it has to do with your view
of what a CEO should be doing and you
know I view I view my job as thinking
about the future yeah I don't I think
that I would under leverage my platform
in my role if I was knee-deep into today
in the operation of today so I have
smart executive out of smart people who
work with me and I do not micromanage i
micro monitor but I don't micromanage he
what does that mean micro monitor means
that I at any point when I need to know
the details I get the details and then
the details allowed me to go deep when I
need to go deep and then I look for
trends and I look for patterns and then
I test whether or not those are
anomalies or in fact represent a problem
so if you are a member and you write me
I take that very seriously and if I get
to that says pretty much the same thing
I go into a deep dive say you know what
I got these to help me understand it and
I've built a culture where everyone
understands this is about being on the
same team this is not a gotcha and and
so that's work that we have we have
going on a big part of my job is outside
of the organization so I spend a
significant amount of time gathering
intelligence around the country and in
fact around the world
how are people thinking what are the
customers talking about what my major
purchasers want from me how's the
government behaving what's on the
horizon and then how do we think about
inside the kaiser permanente five to ten
years from now which is our vision our
vision in Kaiser Permanente the way I
frame that I try to bring clarity to the
long term view of the organization to
deal with if you will our
intentionality I don't try to create the
vision to say I got this blue sky it's
the we are the world of the future it is
to say what everything that I have today
in terms of the assets with where I
think we need to be ten years from now
what are we going to consciously drive
towards in terms of defining our future
and clearly care anywhere is a part of
our future that we are going to figure
out how to turn the home into an
incredible place where future care is
being provided right and we're going to
figure out how to get people as turned
on about the specifics of their body as
they are about an automobile and so the
the wearables and the sensors that are
now just flooding the market we see a
great use of that over time and so in in
in our future someone will be as
interested of how sugar burns to energy
as you are gasoline running a car right
and what happens to the body if you're
not sleeping six to eight hours a day
and then how do you retool yourself in
those situations and in our future
Kaiser Permanente wants to have a bigger
impact on you when you go into grocery
stores then because what you eat is a
precursor to what's going to happen and
so in our model like a digital life
coach yeah yeah thank you and so in our
model some of that stuff
and so that's part of my that's part of
my job and then the other part of my job
is is to continuously be a cheerleader
inside the organization what a couple
quick questions so what what do you guys
how do you think about data patient data
the that as an asset what you can do
with it in terms of new products do you
do you think about that or do you think
about the transaction like the
telemedicine transaction or the ultimate
underlying data that you're generating
and what what can be created or
optimized because of that data all the
data is incredibly important that a good
question yeah it's a great question
the eventually in in our lifetime we are
going to get to precision medicine we
happen to be I call it our fingerprint
medicine right is where each person's
fingerprint the uniqueness of you will
be much better understood in how you
access care and services in the future I
think that is as real as I am talking to
you it's a matter of time the fact that
we are right now dealing with the beauty
of a medication that can cure something
call hepatitis C can cure hepatitis C
it's just a precursor of where we're
going with technology biotechnology
genomics all that is coming together in
the 21st century that's really built
around the ability of technology that's
allowing us to think very differently
behave very differently in old medicine
and a new medicine in old medicine there
were clinical trials and there were
random samples and there were
assumptions made based on that about how
that would affect a big population
and then depending on I mean you gave a
great example of it here's a statin you
give it to this person it seemed to be
fine
you give it at this person and you have
all these problems you go oh it doesn't
work for this person in the future we're
gonna have the ability to be much more
precise about how individuals are
reacting to certain things that comes
with the data the other reason the data
is important inside of Kaiser Permanente
is because we're driving the industry to
understand both individual care and
population health and so the data for us
is critically important because you
start to pick up patterns about the
holistic approach of individuals where
they live
impacts health and our ability to
understand that is critically important
and now we're able to aggregate data in
a way that we can study it very
differently from the rest of the
industry so I know of my 10.5 million
members how many have diabetes and that
information is study to look at best
outcomes based on a variety of
treatments that are provided to this
populations there anything in your way
in terms of collecting that data storing
that data doing things with that data or
is that from a regulatory standpoint is
that not a blocker it's a challenge we
have actually taken the approach to
embrace the regulatory environment one
we don't have a choice and then secondly
is because we are ahead of the
regulation and so in many cases we're
doing things to meet regulatory
requirements they have absolutely no use
in my system because I've put the
technology in place to do what the
regulation is now asking me to do right
and so we're working with them to
understand it we work with them about
the e visits and why it was important to
help us to deal with the HIPAA
requirements while also giving the
access and the physician and the members
to have that kind of virtual interaction
and that's how we got to secure events
got it and then lot last question
officialy is who are you most worried
about maybe not a company but a trend
and what who do you think loses the most
in this sort of new era of health care
from a like a an industry or category
standpoint you can yep I'm like Donald
Trump
I don't worry know I you know I don't
look at it that way I'm I'm more worried
about the other point that you made
which is are we going fast enough so I'm
more worried about as I call it the B
PM's at Kaiser Permanente to beat per
minutes and do I have it above 100 and
and are we executing correctly so I
worry about that a lot in terms of the
ones who are challenged right now it's
more of the solo for example hospitals
who are reading the TVs and they're very
concerned about the future because they
don't have the resources at the level of
that for example we have at Kaiser
Permanente right awesome
no Tyson thank you so much thank you